bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale télé
pour cette nouvelle vidéo plus de lots
une vidéo qui approfondit la première
sur le classement et où on avait vu un
aspect théorique et aussi des
statistiques intéressantes
ici on va voir comment calculer un
premier classement et ensuite on va voir
aussi des données statistiques nouvelles
notamment sur l'histoire comment
calculer le vélo des joueurs des époques
anciennes ou le classement n'était pas
encore là on va voir que c'est possible
et qu'on a des résultats intéressants à
voir
et aussi on verra comment les joueurs
sont répartis en fonction de leur âge
des choses assez intéressantes au niveau
graphique alors en termes de table des
matières tout simplement à un petit
résumé de la dernière fois comment
calcule la différence de points en
fonction du pourcentage de gueule assez
l'opération inverse de ce qu'on a vu sur
l' approche théorique initial on va voir
un exemple ordonne tournoi
comment je fais pour calculer mon
premier classement grâce à cette ce
premier calcul et ensuite on verra donc
ces fameux ces fameuses données et
statistiques sur l'histoire et loué
l'ancien champion et sur les lo fi dès
2015 comment il est réparti selon l'âge
des joueurs on va voir s'il a des choses
intéressantes en terme d'âge alors tout
d'abord un petit résumé donc on avait vu
que le vélo c'est une loi de probabilité
logistique qui nous permettait de
calculer l'espérance de gan joueurs sur
un autre si on connaît leurs classements
respectifs et comment on pouvait faire
évoluer ce classement
bon alors ça ça va bien entre joueurs
qui sont déjà classés mais on n'a pas vu
comment on pouvait calcul est le héros
d'un nouveau joueur ayant un nouveau
joueur il n'a pas encore de classement
on peut pas calculer de différence avec
les autres joueurs on peut pas calculer
le pourcentage de gains théoriques
donc comment on va faire vous allez voir
c'est assez simple là aussi et c'est
assez assez facile finalement une fois
qu'on a compris la méthode et enfin on
va voir aussi comment on peut calculer
grâce à ça à rebours dans le temps de
façon générale je resterai c'est général
va pas faire beaucoup de mater on est
obligé d'en faire un peu parce que le
classement
nous on voit accéder matin bon très bien
mais on fait de façon un peu
superficielle ici et on va voir comment
à rebours dans le temps on va pouvoir
calculer le classement de grands joueurs
anciens et avoir des résultats
intéressants
alors d'abord il nous faut savoir pour
calculer le classement de nouveaux
joueurs
quelle est la différence de points en
fonction du pourcentage de gains que
joueur réussit vous imaginez un nouveau
joueur il fait un premier tournoi il va
réussir un certain pourcentage de gains
il faut qu'on puisse donc calculer
al'inverse quelle va être sa différence
de points elo par rapport à ce
pourcentage alors on avait vu la
dernière fois que la base du classement
elo c'est de dire le pourcentage de
gains il est fonction de cette formule
qui est la fameuse loi logistique un peu
arrangé pour le classement you avec un
facteur 400 ici bon très bien bon
mathématiquement quand on a cette
formule on peut aussi trouver la
différence de point d en fonction du
pourcentage faut faire un peu de maths
je vous passe les détails des
mathématiques je vous donne juste le
résultat c'est ça qui va vous intéresser
pour faire des calculs
après si bien si vous faites un peu de
mathématiques de vous entraîner à faire
l'opération inverse c'est un excellent
exercice de de bon niveau en
mathématiques ce niveau cette différence
de points elo des ça vaudra 400 fois on
retrouve ce 400 bien entendu il n'a pas
disparu
400 fois le logarithme en base 10
attention c'est le logarithme en base 10
a pas confondre avec le logarithme
simple ou le logarithme qu'on appelle
aussi né paie rien qui se note hélène le
log et le nc
sa sé konm di lo lo gharib dans les deux
cas mais c'est pas tout à fait le même
ils sont différentes donc pas le même
résultat quel qu'il soit lié les deux de
façon assez simple
donc c'est logarithme en base 10 de
cette fonction là c'est à dire le
pourcentage réussi / 1 - le pourcentage
donc faut calculer d'abord ça appliqué à
ça le logarithme et le tout faux dans le
x 400 ça peut paraître compliqué ici si
vous n'avez pas fait de maths
si vous avez fait des maths s'adorer
vous paraître assez simple mais même si
vous n'avez pas fait de match vous allez
voir que le calcul avait des chiffres
c'est quand même relativement simple
c'est faisable
donc dès c'est la différence de points
une fois qu'on a calculé dès le nouvel
et l'eau c'est facile c'est la moyenne
et l'eau des joueurs contre qui en a
joué auquel on ajoute cette fameuse
différence de points m + 400 fois le lo
green de ce machin
alors vous allez voir avec un exemple
avant le premier exemple simple on a un
joueur qui réalise une performance de st
berne cinq points sur neuf
dans ce tournoi donc c'est un joueur non
classé
imaginons donc qu'il ait fait ce
résultat
quel est son pourcentage mais c'est ça
il suffit de diviser 5.5 par neuf il a
fait 61 % et il se trouve que dans ce
tournoi l'opposition face à qui il est
et on va voir ça après sur un résultat
plus concret dans un tournoi mais ici
c'est simple on connaît déjà la moyenne
c'est 1675 de trois points elo on peut
donc calculer maintenant son nouveau
classement elo ce joueur qui n'était pas
classé on va d'abord calculées sur cette
fameuse différence de points en fonction
du pourcentage 400 fois donc le
logarithme de quoi et bien le
pourcentage
on avait dit c'est 5 points 5 sur 9 et
donc ça fait 61 % / 1 - 61% un
pourcentage c'est pareil que 61 /
s'annoncer à 10h00 61 donc en hausse et
0.61 / 1 - 0 28 61 ont fait ça la
différence des verts le rapport des deux
on applique le logarithme on multiplie
tout ça par 400 et si vous faites le
calcul vous devriez trouver 77,7 et des
poussières dans la peine d'aller trop
loin le vélo s'arrête à la première
premiers chiffres après la virgule ça
suffit largement
et donc le classement et lowe's
équivalent sera la moyenne plus cette
différence c'est à dire 1675 3 de
moyenne
plus la différence de points on voit
bien qu'il a fait plus de 50%
donc c'est normal qu'ils d un placement
au final qui sera supérieure il va
obtenir un classement ego de 1753 coin
voyez c'est assez simple alors on
appelle aussi ce vélo calculée selon
cette formule la performance ça veut
dire quoi
c'est à dire que le nouvel lots deux
joueurs non classés
c'est donc sa première performance alors
et une petite condition pour pour avoir
un classement elo c'est qu'il faut quand
même obtenir au moins un demi point
à cinq joueurs qui sont déjà classés
pour obtenir son premier classement
voilà donc si vous avez joué face à
moins de cinq joueurs classés eh bien ça
ne fonctionnera pas tout la cfi des bien
sûr voilà parce que les fédérations ont
leur propre classement et parfois vous
allez jouer face à des joueurs clients
classement elo mais qui est pas fidh et
qui est national et dans ce cas là ça ne
marchera pas pour le classement fidh et
ça marchera pour le classement national
alors maintenant un exemple plus concret
plus précis dans un tournoi on a cet
exemple on a un joueur donc et non
classé c'est ça qui nous intéresse il va
jouer donc un premier joie le premier
tournoi pardon en sept rondes et ils
affrontent les joueurs suivants avec le
résultat qui suit première ronde ils
jouent face à un joueur classé avec un
lots de 1850
résultat zéro c'est à dire il a perdu la
partie deuxième ronde il a joué face à
un nom placé donc là ça comptera pas
cette deuxième ronald compte pour du
beurre
pour son classement elo pas pour le
tournoi pour le tournoi ce point il va
marquer bien sûr mais pour le classement
rio il pourra pas être pris en compte
on ne tiendra compte que des joueurs qui
ont déjà un classement il va marquer un
ici ensuite un ensuite une nulle une
perte
une guerre est en phase héros donc il
nous faut calculer deux choses la
moyenne et l'eau des joueurs classés
alors évidemment on n'a que six
résultats puisque la deuxième ronde il
était non classés on ne prend pas en
compte ce résultat numéro deux il faut
calculer 1850 plus 1650 piscine etc
et le tout divisé par six on obtient une
moyenne de 1650 8,3 points elo
maintenant le pourcentage de gains c'est
quoi le pourcentage de guerre baisser
les points qu'il a marqué sauf la
deuxième toujours pareil il faut pas
raconter puisqu'ils n'étaient pas placés
donc zéro au plus un plus un demi plus
zéro + 1 + 0 / 6 puisqu'on ne compte pas
donc la deuxième et on obtient
pourcentage de 41 7% donc là tilt
attention il a fait un résultat
inférieur à 50 %
donc on s'attend à ce qu'il ait un
classement inférieur à la moyenne
pas supérieur ça veut dire que dans
notre formule théorique qu'on vient de
voir
on devrait retrouver un résultat négatif
en terme de différence de points si
votre résultat est pas négatif c'est
forcément que vous vous êtes trompés
dans le calcul donc on en déduit donc la
performance selon le calcul qu'on a vu
précédemment avec la formule m la
moyenne pour la paire ce sera donc la
moyenne c'est à dire ici 1658 3 plus
donc 400 fois le lob de attention donc
on remplace 41 7 % c'est-à-dire 0.4 117
/ 1 - 0 2 417 et donc on va obtenir
cette fameuse moyenne mi-séance
continuelle 3 et on a bien moins quand
vous fruits ce calcul 400 fois le log
ici de ce machin
ça vous fera quelque chose de négatif
58,2 et donc vous allez obtenir un
classement final de 1600 1,1 point quand
vous avez joué ici six joueurs déjà
classé c'est plus de 5
vous avez bien réussi plus de un demi
point puisque vous avez fait même deux
et demi ce qui est mieux et donc vous
aurez un premier classement ici dans ce
cas-là précis de 1600 1,1 point au
classement elo internationale ou
nationale ça marche
théoriquement ça devrait marcher après
pareil dans les deux cas bon en réalité
parfois certaines fédérations des
calculs de l'eau un tout petit peu
différente de celle de la fille d mais
en gros grosso modo c'est quand même
très proche
alors maintenant on va voir
après cela se calcule que vous pouvez
donc refaire vous pouvez arrêter la
vidéo sur ce qu'on a vu essayer de
refaire le calcul pour être sûr d'y
arriver et vous pourrez sur des
résultats de grid au tournoi à vérifier
que vous avez bien compris et pouvoir
calculer ainsi des estimations et au
alors on va voir que donc dans
l'histoire on peut re calcul et les lots
des grands champions alors pour avoir
plus de détails sur ça on va juste avoir
des résultats il ya une page dans
wikipédia sur wikipédia qui est
malheureusement qu en anglais pour
l'instant ça n'a pas été traduit en
français ça viendra peut-être qu'ils se
nomment complot leisen of key player
fallout history c'est à dire la
comparaison donc des joueurs de top
niveau
à travers l'histoire comment ils ont
fait ça alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que on peut faire de différentes façons
mais essentiellement
ils ont tous les résultats des tournois
dans l'histoire ils ont tous les
résultats des joueurs ont d'après rondes
dans les tournois alors peut-être ou
peut-être pas tous les tournois qui ont
été joués ils en ont quand même beaucoup
donc ça leur permet notamment pour les
joueurs de top niveau international qui
avait et bien eu des retransmissions
lors de leur tournoi même dans les
années 1850 et 1900 dans les journaux et
donc on peut récupérer ces informations
elles ont été compilés et on a pu
recalculer le classement elo historique
de ces grands joueurs et on a pu les
recalculés mois après mois alors que
initialement le hello historique en 1970
il été publié que tous les ans
évidemment quand on a tous les résultats
de toutes les parties on peut refaire
même le résultat jour après jour de tous
les joueurs et c'est le classement elo
historique et remonte jusqu en 1843 ça
s'il ya un site sur internet qui
s'appelle chess metrics point commun
c'est en anglais mais qui présente ses
résultats vous avez le classement -
après mois de 1843 jusqu'à nos jours et
on retrouve des joueurs historiques
comme saint-amand comme steinitz
évidemment comme l'as caire et comme
stanton l'anglais voilà et donc des
grands joueurs de l'époque 19e siècle et
tout le xxème siècle si bien sûr et bien
avant le premier classement et
l'officiel de 1970 donc rétroactivement
on a pu donc calculé grâce aux partis
aux résultats surtout des partis et des
tournois qui ont été stockés de ces
grands joueurs
alors ça vous donne quand même des
résultats très intéressants à regarder
si on regarde le classement ici alors
ici c'est le pic soit annuel soit sur
cinq ans soit sur 10 ans soit sur 15 ans
soit sur 20 ans je crois que c'est la
moyenne donc ils regardent le pic c'est
à dire les joueurs qui avaient le plus
haut classement sur ces périodes là en
moyenne donc par exemple pour
sur un an et bien c'est bobby fischer
qui aurait atteint selon ce classement
le niveau de 2008 181 points
alors attention et c'est un recalcul qui
a été fait mensuellement qui reprend un
calcul de type logistique et pas
forcément un calcul de type loi normale
comme c'était initialement donc les
placements seront ici un peu différent
des classements historiquement de
publier par la fille des mets ont ils
ont calculé ce classement quand même de
la même façon pour tous les joueurs
pour ce qui nous intéresse ici c'est ça
puisqu'on peut du coup comparer ses
joueurs dans dans le temps par par ce
biais alors regardez donc on retrouve
kasparov bobigny capablanca quatrième
capablanca comme qui je vous rappelle
quand même été champion du monde dans
les années 20 la sq air qui était
champion du monde entre 1905 je crois et
1920 par l'ajustement il allait il a
passé la main à casablanca
il restait 15 ou 20 ans champion la sq
croit que ces mêmes 20 ans est allé
keane qui était donc champion jusque
jusqu'en 48 dans les années 30 jusqu'en
1948 voilà donc les très grands ici
champions on voit aussi alors pour les
lepic de 20 ans regardez c'est très
intéressant puisqu'on retrouve des
joueurs classés dans un ordre différent
kasparov et karpov laskey revoilà il
trop jours quand il les règnes les plus
longs en tant que domination du
classement on retrouve bien ces trois
grands champions du monde à liqin aussi
mais surtout pas loin et puis on
retrouve cornouaille qui dont on sait
qu'il a une immense carrière jusque
jusque encore à nos jours un cornouaille
qui a joué pendant très très longtemps
et qui est arrivé deux fois en finale du
championnat du monde
tu crois que c'est dans toute la liste
qu'on voit là c'est le seul qui n'a pas
obtenu le titre mais on voit quand même
que au niveau du niveau lots sur 20 ans
eh bien ils auraient mérité très
certainement rejoindre le niveau des
champions du monde
obtenir un titre voilà il smith l'offre
lui-même avait a été champion du monde
alors il ya beaucoup d'autres
statistiques intéressantes et évidemment
quand on a le classement - après -
depuis 1843 on trouve des pépites des
choses très intéressantes on va pas tout
commenter ici je vous donne la piste
vous avez l'article wikipédia à les voir
en anglais pourquoi pas commencer à le
traduire en français où aller chercher
des informations sur ces sites qui sont
vraiment très intéressante et qui
mériterait d'être peut-être un peu plus
connu est maintenant donc on va voir la
répartition du et l'ofii des parages
vous allez voir si très intéressant
alors tout d'abord je reviens sur le
classement fides général ça c'est la
répartition des joueurs dans le
classement fis des général 2015
simplement pour vous rappeler qu'on
retrouve bien notre fameuse répartition
logistique avec un tig et dont on a
parlé dans la vidéo qui explique en
détail
je reviens pas dessus juste pour vous
remettre en tête cette courbe
maintenant on va voir une course très
différente vous allez voir est assez
riche attention est difficile à voir
quand même du beau au premier coup
d'oeil vous allez voir les très
intéressante
voilà c'est cette vidéo
cette part dans cette
cette image 3d qui est en fait une série
de courbes logistiques donc les
premières en fait ici son cachet au
niveau droit mais comme c'est à peu près
symétrique ça c'est pas très intéressant
en avoir toute la courbe
c'est mieux de les avoir toutes ici pour
pouvoir les comparer regardez comment ça
se passe alors comment ça se passe ici
là vous avez l'âge sur ce lac si si qui
est en profondeur 0 donc ll601 d'âge
jusqu'à cent ans d'âge donc zéro au fond
100 ans vers nous donc c'est comme ça
que c'est là c'est ici c'est le
classement elo
donc ça veut dire qu on a bien le pic
ici qui représente la moyenne et le plus
de nombre le plus de joueurs classés à
ce niveau là au niveau du pic et on voit
bien que ce pic ici voilà il est présent
sur chaque courbe est bon il va rien
c'est à dire que là on voit bien que
pour les jeunes joueurs ici bon eh bien
il part bien sûr de 1000 lots pour
atteindre ici une moyenne top ici autour
de deux mille lots et puis ensuite ça
tient ou ça tient à peu près leur 2000
héros épique plus l'âge avance plus ça
descend alors ça descend si avec le
nombre de joueurs qui diminue forcément
on est à 90 95 cents ans
forcément ça diminue ici en termes de
nombre de joueurs et aussi en termes de
moyenne sa baisse un peu mais pas tant
que ça les anciennes joue encore très
bien aux échecs
voyez donc a aussi des différences il ya
des creux que l'on retrouve aussi
attention on a des données
démographiques
il ya eu des guerres et ce genre de
choses donc qui joue aussi sur la
répartition des joueurs donc il faut pas
en tirer une loi trop général non plus à
noter qu'ici le pic ici le joueur est
représentée par les joueurs entre 20 et
25 ans et là où donc où il y en a le
plus en taille
alors pourquoi et sans doute parce que
c'est une activité quand même ludique et
sportive qu'on peut pratiquer plus
facilement quand on a encore
25 ans qu'on est encore un peu étudiants
alors que quand on commence à être soit
occupé par sa famille ou par un travail
prenant forcément bien on joue moins et
moins actifs et donc ça se ressent dans
les effectifs aussi et donc celles à la
population la plus dense en terme de
nombre de joueurs et aussi en tant que
moyenne attention la moyenne est pas
meilleur c'est on est en trois
dimensions ici il faut il faut juste
avoir un petit oeil ici la moyenne est à
peu près semblable pour une bonne ici
une bonne période de temps jusqu'à 50 60
ans la moyenne change pas trop et
toujours admin en fait voilà quel que
soit l'âge simplement le nombre de
joueurs est pas le même
alors à noter ici que la courbe ici en
bleu clair c'est les joueurs classés
pour l'âge entre 15 et 20 ans voilà donc
on voit bien qu ici entre 15 et
maintenant qu'ils sont pas moins
nombreux qu'entre 20 et 25
alors attention c'est le classement
international uniquement donc c'est pas
le classement des fédérations nationales
donc quand la fédération internationale
ne classe pas n'a pas intégré tous les
joueurs on peut avoir beaucoup plus de
joueurs d'âge moindre dans les jeunes
générations que ce qui apparaît ici dans
la réalité des clubs voilà il faut
garder en tête qu'il s'agit du
classement uniquement fidh et
internationale voilà donc c'est quand
même intéressant de voir comment et bien
chaque génération ici de d'âge de
joueurs et bien voit sa courbe
logistique se modifier au cours du temps
il se transformer un peu et jusqu'à bah
oui disparaître mais ça c'est du halage
voilà une information nouvelle aussi sur
ce classement elo qui permet de faire un
peu de démographie et de et aussi de
niveau 2 points elo donc deux niveaux
échiquéen voilà donc cette vidéo arrive
à son terme
sur ce classement elo donc on a vu ce
premier classement et aussi donc ces
données statistiques sur l'histoire un
petit peu des anciens champions et cette
répartition par parages voilà merci de
m'avoir suivi sur des modèles tv et jeux
vous donne donc rendez-vous à bientôt
pour d'autres vidéos au revoir